and basically we need the continued
support from the political level because
it's not only the money it is also the
actions in the Nations that lead to more
radio forces and the capabilities we
need and if you actually see that in the
seven years before the war the budgets
went up already but the industry did not
increase the production capacity
and that has led to higher prices
already before the war and that actually
has exacerbated by the fact that we now
give away weapon systems to Ukraine
which is great and ammunition but not
from Full warehouses we started to give
away from half full or lower warehouses
in Europe and therefore the bottom of
the barrel is now visible
and we need the industry to ramp up
production in a much higher Tempo and we
need large volumes at the just in time
just enough economy that we built
together in 30 years in our liberal
economies is fine for a lot of things
but not for uh for for the Armed Forces
when there is a war ongoing where you
have Peak demand signals like we saw in
the pandemic with medical equipment
uh
machine
um
foreign